SIERRA: We had been planning to do an episode
on international students, visas and the education
system for the past few months.
It seems like an underreported topic that
people should know about.
But then, it became part of the news.
CBS: Students’ whose schools plan to offer
online only classes in the fall will have
to transfer or leave the country or face possible
deportation.
CTV: Several prestigious American universities
are now suing the Trump Administration.
MSNBC: The Trump Administration backed down,
but I don’t think it’s the end for what
we might see from the Administration.
SIERRA: You could be forgiven for thinking
that student visas are a classic partisan
issue in American politics - liberals pushing
for cultural diversity and a more open society
while conservatives warn of dangers to national
security and American jobs.
But the real story is quite different.
For decades Republicans and Democrats agreed
that a steady pipeline of the world’s best
minds into American universities is essential
for our economy, innovation, and competitive
advantage with the rest of the world.
It was a system that largely worked.
The Trump administration has taken a different
perspective, and the pipeline of international
students into American businesses, hospitals,
and research facilities has begun to constrict.
As this happens, other nations have begun
picking up the slack.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters.
Today, international students, and American
competitiveness, under threat.
SIERRA: Alright, so I'm a student in another
country, why do I want to come to school in
the United States?
ALDEN: I mean, if you look at the lists of
the world's 100 best universities, more than
half of those are in the United States.
You know, if you come here and you graduate
with a degree from a top American University
that's worth a tremendous amount throughout
your life.
My name is Edward Alden.
I'm a senior fellow at the Council on Foreign
Relations.
I'm also the Ross distinguished visiting professor
at Western Washington University in Bellingham,
Washington.
SIERRA: Alden is a leading voice on immigration,
innovation, and US competitiveness.
He spends a lot of time studying the contributions
of immigrants to the US economy.
ALDEN: I mean, secondarily, even if you're
not coming to the best institutions, I mean,
the United States has a global reputation
as a dynamic, innovative place and if you're
a talented ambitious foreign student, it's
a place you want to be.
I mean, finally education is an English and
English remains the universal language of
business.
So, you know, to the extent that you come
out from an American education with a strong
grasp of the English language, that's something
also going to be very helpful in your life.
BRIMMER: There are liberal arts colleges,
there are research institutions, institutions
large and small that can cater to many different
types of learning and covering many different
styles.
My name is Esther Brimmer.
I'm Executive Director and CEO of NAFSA, the
Association of International Educators.
So bright students around the world know they
can come here and get a great education.
And perhaps one of the most exciting things
is the dynamism of the American classroom.
That is very rare, that idea of having an
interactive classroom where students and professors
are talking to each other, where the learning
is shared, it's not just the professor lecturing.
And I'll tell you as someone who was a former
professor, I love that environment.
And indeed, it's something where we even put
out a publication on introduction to the American
classroom to help students get used to the
idea that they will have to defend their ideas.
SIERRA: Ok, so you decide you want to come
to school in the U.S.
How does the system actually work?
What are the options for getting a visa?
ALDEN: Well, you need to be admitted to the
university that you wish to attend.
So that's the same thing an American student
would face.
You have to apply to the university and write
your admissions essay, all the things that
American students do when they want to attend
a university.
If you are admitted, then you need to apply
for what's called an f1 student visa, the
visa does not allow you to remain in the United
States permanently, does not allow you to
work for income with some exceptions while
you're in the United States.
It's a temporary visa that permits you to
come here and study.
SIERRA: Alongside the F-1, there are also
J1 visas, and a few other lesser-known options.
Together they account for roughly 1.1 million
foreign students in the US.
For anyone who has done it or helped someone
do it, you know that applying to college is
not easy.
Even with some assistance from family or a
guidance counselor.
For an international student, it also means
travelling to an embassy or consulate in their
home country, and going through a meticulous
and costly process to get a visa.
And it isn’t as though they get to breathe
a sigh of relief once they are accepted, or
even after they arrive.
BRIMMER: For many students, it may be their
first time out of their home country.
Maybe their family has all saved up their
money to send their bright child to the US.
That's a big commitment by the child of the
family.
When they get to the United States, their
institutions, of course, comply with the law.
And some people may not realize, but every
international student is actually, in effect,
tracked by its institution.
In other words, there is an official at each
institution that has to know where that student
is, and be able to file documentation on them.
So unlike any other visitor to the United
States, business travelers, tourists, only
international students are actually recorded
and tracked with that level of detail.
So the student has a lot of obligations, a
lot of costs, and their institutions have
additional obligations as well.
It's a big commitment, a very big commitment,
but it's a life changing commitment.
Tracy: It’s funny how wide eyed I was when
I first came to study in America.
I dreamed about so many things, the freedom,
the opportunities.
Lingua Marina: America, I think, is one of
the best countries in terms of having great
people teach students.
NBC: The cultural exchange that you get in
the U.S., you don’t get it anywhere else
in the world.
Education USA: After studying here, you can
go anywhere and do whatever you want to do.
SIERRA: Okay, so you're here for let's say
the two or four potentially, I guess, eight
years.
You know, what happens once you graduate?
ALDEN: You can say ‘thank you very much,
United States.
I've enjoyed my time in my education here’
and you can go back to your home country.
And that's what a lot of foreign students
do.
If you want to stay and work for a US company,
the only real option is what they call the
H1-B Visa Program, which allows US companies
to hire foreign citizens who have at least
a bachelor's degree.
That program is quota capped at 65,000 per
year and there's always more demand than there
is supply but they're an extra 20,000 spots
for foreign students graduating with advanced
degrees from American universities.
So particularly if you're working in, you
know, engineering or technical or scientific
fields, there's a reasonably good chance that
you can find an American company that will
want to bring you on under an H1-B visa.
SIERRA: The H1-B visa is a crucial part of
the international student pipeline - it’s
what allows them to remain in the U.S. and
join the workforce.
Many of these students go on to become citizens,
found companies, and create jobs.
ALDEN: You could make a pretty strong argument
that foreign students are at the heart of
US success as-as the most innovative economy
in the world.
I mean, they have brought tremendous benefits.
Maybe you fill in the history a bit.
Basically, going back to the 1950s, the United
States began to encourage foreign students
to come here.
And a lot of that was essentially a diplomatic
initiative.
We wanted to build up friends around the world.
I mean, it's the same reason the Fulbright
program was created to send American students
and faculty abroad.
We thought that if foreign students came here,
and they studied in the United States, they
got to see what life in the United States
was like that that would bring benefits down
the road when these people went back home,
they would look favorably upon the United
States.
I mean, there are dozens of foreign leaders
who were educated at universities in the United
States.
Former Secretary of State Colin Powell used
to say that these educational exchanges were
the best diplomatic program the United States
had, that it did more than anything else to
win us friends around the world.
SIERRA: When international students go home,
they bring American soft power back with them.
And that’s because they’ve had the chance
to see the U.S. with their own eyes, in all
its contradictions and diversity of values.
Not just what’s seen on the news in their
home countries.
Many of them, however, choose to stay.
And when they do, they often turn out to be
innovators.
ALDEN: So the second big benefit to the United
States comes from the foreign students who
study here and then decide to stay and make
their careers in the United States.
And the number of those has been growing substantially,
particularly in the so called STEM fields,
you know, science, technology, engineering
and math, that are so important to American
innovation.
You go back to the late 80s US universities
were graduating about 25,000 foreign students
in the STEM fields.
Today, it's close to 125,000.
And the overwhelming majority of those students
remain and make their careers here in the
United States.
The retention rate is about 75%.
And it's higher than that, importantly, for
Chinese and Indian students who are by far
the two largest cohorts of foreign students,
especially in the STEM fields, the retention
rate there for Chinese is about 90%.
And it's pretty close for Indians.
And you know, if you look, for instance, at
the history of Silicon Valley, almost half
of Silicon Valley companies had at least one
foreign citizen as their founders.
And most of them went to American universities.
BRIMMER: It is really fascinating to look
at the so called ‘unicorn companies,’
the startups that are now valued at over $1
billion, that a quarter of them were founded
by international students, people who came
here to study and then eventually were able
to create businesses.
They've directly contributed to the wealth
of the United States and the well being of
the United States.
SIERRA: The data is conclusive about international
students creating jobs.
Sometimes this happens on a small scale, other
times you can get someone like Elon Musk,
who founded PayPal, Tesla, and SpaceX after
studying in the U.S. A lesser-known but no
less important name is Noubar Afeyan, an international
student of biochemical engineering at MIT,
who went on to found 38 companies in his career.
One of those companies, Moderna, helped develop
the first COVID vaccine to be tested in humans.
And even before they graduate, international
students make an enormous economic contribution
through tuition.
BRIMMER: In addition to the important intellectual
benefits, there are significant economic benefits
to having international students and scholars
in the United States.
According to our most recent study, international
students and scholars contribute $41 billion
to the United States economy.
They account for over 458,000 jobs.
And those contributions are spread across
the country.
After all, many international students pay
full fare, that means that they in effect
are helping finance the American students
sitting next to them in the classroom.
It's a real contribution and a real benefit
to the United States.
SIERRA: Seems like a sweetheart deal for the
U.S, and yet for years we’ve been losing
our edge in attracting the best international
students.
At the same time, attitudes toward them have
been growing more hostile.
We’ll dive into all that and more after
a quick break.
So in July, as the US was grappling with the
COVID pandemic, another topic began making
headlines.
The Trump administration announced a plan
that would upend the lives of international
students studying in the US.
ALDEN: The original regulation said unless
you're taking an in person class, you're going
to have to return to your countries because
you know, you can do online from India as
well as you can do it from the United States,
I mean, forgetting that, you know, that's
on the opposite side of the world, and so
you’d be taking classes in the middle of
the night.
BRIMMER: We saw major universities file legal
cases to have this proposal stopped.
And what was amazing to see was the outpouring
of support.
You saw all sorts of different types of business
groups.
You saw educational groups, you saw social
You saw religious groups.
You saw communities and institutions and people,
international students and scholars and their
American counterparts, students and scholars
saying, ‘we want to have international students
here, we want to be sure that they're welcome.
We want to be sure that even if their courses
go online, that they won't fall out of status’.
And it was remarkable in such a short period
of time to see that kind of swelling up of
support for international students and scholars.
CBS: The announcement by ICE fueled strong
criticism from students, colleges, universities
and lawmakers, including some republicans
typically aligned with the White House.
MSNBC:What we’re simply saying to the Administration
is “Stop.”
Democracy Now: It’s not the foreign students’
faults, and to be honest, they are one of
the most valuable assets that this country
has.
MSNBC: It’s not time to shun those who have
excelled in their fields simply because they
are not American born.
ALDEN: I mean, I think some of that is this
recognition of the broad value that foreign
students have to the United States.
But I think it also kind of galvanized this
awareness that we really haven't been treating
foreign students very well, in some ways for
a couple of decades, but particularly in the
last few years.
They really are taken for granted.
I think their contributions to the United
States are poorly understood.
And so I think this action really did bring
a pretty strong, coordinated response.
I mean, it was noteworthy that the administration,
largely, though not completely, backed down
on the eve of the hearing for a lawsuit that
was spearheaded by Harvard and MIT.
And I think it's pretty clear the judge would
have slapped the administration down for this
order.
And so the administration largely though I
say, not completely, reversed course.
So in the revised rule, those students will
be able to stay.
But new foreign students, those who are getting
visas for programs starting this fall, unless
they have at least one face to face class,
they're not going to be admitted to the country.
And so there are going to be a lot of foreign
students who were hoping to attend in the
fall of 2020 who are not going to be allowed
to attend under this new rule.
So there's going to be a significant decline
in new foreign students as a consequence of
that rule.
And at the moment, it doesn't look like the
universities are going to challenge this,
they're going to live with a compromise.
SIERRA: This decline could affect the entire
pipeline - fewer students beginning their
studies could mean fewer students moving on
to Silicon Valley, fewer starting businesses
that could employ Americans during a recession.
And while the July action and the backlash
against it were dramatic, it’s important
to realize that the changes didn’t start
there.
BRIMMER: So even before the pandemic, there
had been nearly an 11% decline in the number
of new students coming to the United States.
The travel bans instituted early in 2017 and
then the related issues to that have sent
a message to some international students and
scholars that they're not welcome in the United
States and that's been a real concern.
That sends a message, not only to those from
specific countries cited in the executive
order, but to all students.
[They] began to wonder ‘if this country's
on the list, could my country be next?
Would that mean that maybe I can't get a visa?’
SIERRA: As U.S. policy becomes more severe,
places like Canada, the UK, New Zealand and
Australia have gained a competitive edge.
In 2018 and 2019, as the pipeline was constricting
in the U.S., Canada saw double-digit growth
in its international students.
It’s already starting to reap the benefits
in terms of job creation, university income,
and innovation.
ALDEN: The situation seemed pretty stable
when President Trump came to office in 2017.
Under the Trump administration, there has
been quite a sharp turn of direction.
The-the administration has a different view
about foreign students than you know, what
has been the strong consensus here for decades.
Their belief is, first, that foreign students
are taking positions in the universities away
from American students.
If a foreign student’s being admitted, that's
an American student who doesn't have a seat
at the institution.
Therefore that's a negative for Americans.
Also quite a strong conviction in the administration
that when foreign students remain and go to
work for US companies, they're also taking
jobs away from American citizens.
So the administration has been doing a number
of things to try to discourage foreign students.
The student visa process has become longer
and more onerous.
There'll be limited work opportunities for
foreign students after they graduate.
Administration has been curtailing in various
ways the H1-B program, which is so important
for foreign students who want to stay and
work.
SIERRA: As the Trump administration rolls
back options for international students to
study and work in the US, misinformation about
them has been spreading.
Sometimes answers to even the most basic questions
are hard to find.
So, we asked Edward Alden to field four of
the most common ones.
SIERRA: Are foreign students taking up slots
at schools that would otherwise go to American
students?
ALDEN: Sometimes.
The research suggests that at the elite institutions,
probably yes.
You know, if you're at a Stanford where the
acceptance rate is, I don't know 6% or 3%,
or whatever, there’s no question, sometimes
foreign students are getting places that are
not going to American students.
On the whole, the research suggests that the
more foreign students we have in the United
States, the more places in total there are
for Americans.
They may be at other institutions, but the
economic benefits from foreign students make
the universities stronger, they're able to
expand, and therefore there are more places
in total.
SIERRA: So the pie gets bigger as opposed
to just you know, getting devoured with none
left.
ALDEN: The pie on the whole gets bigger, but
you know, Stanford and Harvard and Yale don't
get any bigger.
SIERRA: Okay.
After students graduate, are they stealing
American jobs?
ALDEN: Again, mostly, no.
I mean, the evidence is that foreign students
because of the companies they start after
they go to work are creating a lot more jobs
than they're taking away.
In some places, yeah, definitely.
I mean, sometimes, you know, a foreign student
gets hired where an American doesn't.
But in the aggregate, far more jobs created
for Americans, by the activities of these
students when they stay, then jobs that are
somehow taken away from Americans.
So there too the pie is getting bigger.
SIERRA: Are spies from authoritarian countries
like China posing as foreign students in order
to steal sensitive information or technology
that could then be misused?
ALDEN: This is a complicated one, right?
Because, you know, Chinese students are the
single largest cohort of foreign students
in the United States.
But you also have this growing economic, technological
and military rivalry between the United States
and China.
And there's absolutely no question that the
Chinese have sent over researchers, that there
are Chinese students who are acting effectively
as, as, as spies here in the United States
trying to glean secrets from companies, trying
to recruit people in the United States, to
spy on the United States, trying to use every
tool they have to gain an advantage in the
competition between China and the United States.
So there is absolutely a need for targeted
interventions to try to identify these security
concerns.
Arrest people where appropriate.
Make sure that American Universities are aware
of this threat.
But there's a big difference between that
sort of targeted response and the kind of
blanket actions the administration is considering.
It's been talking about, you know, an across
the board ban on Chinese students who are
working in science and technology fields,
and that would just be tremendously costly
to the United States and an absolute shot
in the foot.
So, yes, Chinese espionage is a real concern.
No, the solution is not to bar Chinese students
from coming to the United States, that would
be an action whose consequences are far worse
than the problem.
SIERRA: So what about the students who come
here, get a good American education and then
take those skills home?
Do you think that's hurting the United States?
ALDEN: I mean, by and large, no.
Again, the research here is pretty clear.
I mean, if they go back and work in companies,
you can see actually far closer relations
between companies headed by foreign students
who studied in the United States and the United
States.
They're inclined to, you know, buy components
from the United States, to export products
to the United States, to engage in trade with
the United States.
I mean, the only potential area of concern,
getting back to the previous question is if
they're learning things that may be useful
to foreign militaries, or other things that
could somehow be used against the United States.
But to some extent, it's sort of a fool's
game to try to control that kind of knowledge.
I mean, in the modern world, information,
ideas, knowledge flow, very, very freely.
SIERRA: So how do you think the student visa
issue has intersected with overall immigration
policy under the Trump administration?
ALDEN: Yeah, this is a really interesting
question because it marks the biggest difference
between the Trump administration and previous
administrations, both Republican and Democratic.
The immigration debate in the United States
for about three decades now has been largely
about legal versus illegal immigration.
And there's been a strong consensus in both
parties that legal immigration is an enormous
net benefit for the United States.
It's a good thing.
We want people coming here legally, we want
them to move to the United States.
We want them to contribute to our economy
and our society.
The problem is illegal immigration, and that
was, you know, strong consensus kind of from
the mid 1990s.
And so most of what Congress tried to do,
mostly failed to do but tried to do, was was
come up with reforms that would be generous
on the legal immigration side, but would do
more to crack down on illegal immigration.
The Trump administration has a different view
of the world, they think immigration generally
is not a good thing for the United States.
And so where this intersects with the student
visa discussion is, you know, if you're in
favor of legal immigration, you're inclined
to see these foreign students as kind of the
cream of the crop, right?
These are the most highly educated people
coming from around the world.
They're advancing their education at our excellent
institutions, and these are going to be the
legal immigrants who are going to make the
largest contributions to the economy.
And so you had in both parties generally a
lot of enthusiasm for the program.
Under the Trump administration, it's much
more ‘No, these foreign students are unwanted
competition for Americans.’
And particularly as a result of Coronavirus,
which has, of course has done so much damage
to the economy and pushed unemployment well
up into the double digits, the administration
is using that as a rationale for saying, ‘Well,
now in particular, we really need to keep
immigrants out and we need to save the jobs
that are being created for Americans’.
So the administration has used the pandemic
as a pretext for further cutting back on legal
immigration.
I mean most people haven't really noticed
this because it's happened through a whole
series of actions, but legal immigration to
the United States is about half of what it
was four years ago.
So students are not the only group being affected
by this at all.
BRIMMER: Several years of policies that projected
an anti-foreigner message take their toll.
The rise in xenophobia takes its toll.
If there continue to be policies that come
out that threaten their ability to comply
with the status or create such ambiguity that
they don't know whether they'll be able to
study that will send a message to the world
that the US does not want to have international
students.
And that's not the case.
People on campuses do want to have international
students.
But if they see national policies that say
the opposite it makes it very, very hard for
educators to welcome the students the way
they would like to.
ALDEN: The US is losing the status it had
as unquestionably the number one destination
of choice for foreign students.
All of the political and immigration and visa
hassles that have been exacerbated by this
administration are sending a very clear message
to foreign students that, you know, if you
want to go to the United States, you want
to stay there, it's going to be a very difficult
journey.
So why not look for easier options in other
places?
SIERRA: So, do you think that we can recover
our reputation?
Or is the damage already done?
ALDEN: That is a fabulous question.
And you know, I'm going to give an annoying
‘I don't know.’
If you look at them at the modern history
of this, the resilience of the United States
is pretty extraordinary.
I mean, we did you know, we did a lot of fairly
unpleasant things to foreign students after
9/11.
There were some damaging things that were
done because of our fear in the immediate
aftermath of the attacks.
But you had the Bush administration at the
time, which very much believed foreign students
were good for the United States trying to
fix those errors and put out the welcome mat
again.
You know, I don't want to get particularly
partisan here, but if President Trump is reelected,
then I think you're going to see that as a
vindication for his protectionist policies
on immigration and trade in other areas.
And I think then we will really see a generation’s
worth of damage in terms of foreign students
coming.
If there's a different outcome, I think the
US can still recover its ground here.
You know, you hinted at this at the outset,
in one of your questions.
I mean, I've mostly been talking about sort
of hard stuff like economic performance and,
you know, the high politics of diplomacy.
But obviously, there are just tremendous benefits
to the mixing of young people from other places,
you know, I mean, this is why we have a Peace
Corps program.
This is why, you know, you have the Fulbright
scholarships to send US students abroad, and
it's one of the big reasons we want to bring
foreign students here.
You know, we want our young people to get
to know people from other cultures, to get
to know people that speak different languages,
to be exposed to different ways of looking
at the world, to make friends from other backgrounds
and other cultures.
And it's hard to quantify the benefits from
that but I think it's pretty obviously a good
thing.
And I think that's something we really want
to continue to encourage as a country and
nurture and I hope we are not going to keep
going in the wrong direction.
SIERRA: Want to learn more about the future
for international students?
Head to CFR.org/WhyItMatters for the show
notes from this episode.
Interested in saying ‘hey’ to the Why
It Matters team?
You can always reach out on email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
If you are a fan, subscribe to the show on
Apple Podcasts, Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever
you get your audio.
And if you like what you hear, leave us a
review!
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Jeremy
Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me, Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria and our
summer intern is Wynne Dieffenbach.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Sarah Shaw gave us extra help with this episode,
and we are very, very grateful.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra,
signing off.
See you soon!